hello everyone and welcome to anthem I'm
Ben Irving one of the lead produces for
the game and on behalf of everyone here
at Bioware we are excited to share this
live gameplay experience with all of you
joining me today are four amazing
developers controllers in hand ready to
take you on an adventure through the
mysterious world of anthem now second
karabasan hit another one Contras
getting far now strangest says fine you
guys starting without me
freelancer time to get to work they said
these bastard made some kind of acid be
using it as a weapon look at a couple
supply caravans scarce taken down whole
caravans damn I know should make this a
challenge yeah
I like a challenge uh who gets lucky
juicy yes yes
so find where they're making this
garbage and shut it all down
he's at gate right
our expedition starts in the players
Strider this is your forward base of
operations here you can equip your
javelin with a wide array of gear
weapons and abilities as well as
customize your appearance to show off
your own personal style and flair in
front of us we have the Colossus Jen
will be our squad leader today so Jen
let's jump in and get started at the
start of any expedition we need to
decide who we want to play with general
be inviting two of her friends but when
you play the game you would choose from
your friends guild mates other
like-minded individuals or even go out
and explore the world on your own now
that our squad is formed we need to pick
our objective this is the map screen and
as you can see there are a lot of
different activities to choose from but
today we'll be playing the mission scars
and villainy anthem is a social co-op
action RPG from Bioware where you will
join a group called the freelancers the
freelancers of the brave few who go out
into the wild and face danger head-on
they can do this because they are
equipped with powerful javelin exosuits
these javelins a handcrafted and passed
down from generation to generation
allowing those who have them to go out
into the wild and feel super heroic
[Music]
today we will play from Jen's
perspective in her Colossus a heavily
armored battle XO that trades agility
for massive firepower as you can see her
two friends have joined us Ranade is
playing in the Ranger a faster moving
javelin with a focus on precision Siller
is also playing a colossus but with a
completely different loadout one that
focuses on close quarter combat and will
see his flamethrower a bit later on he
also has a totally different appearance
with that sweet sweet red speed stripe
houses an unfinished world a world
abandoned by its gods the shapers it's
also a reactive world here you can see
our Jets overheating but we can fly
through this waterfall to cool them off
Owen what's the plan here picking up
loads of scars nearby take a look around
the area but sir be careful
Owen is our cipher and guide for the
mission and will provide valuable Intel
[Music]
the scars are relentless invaders who
crazy ancient power of the shape of
technology and they're in a constant
conflict with the freelancers
[Music]
up ahead we have asked our watchtower
our squad should probably tread lightly
here so they don't call for
reinforcements oh we could just blow it
up look at all the weapons so and their
other turrets that I move quickly
there is acid here but not much they're
gonna be making it farther in right
checking out the scar camp some more
missions can be joined in progress
through freelancer reinforcements alpha
squad member Catherine is about to join
us
Catherine joined us in the storm a glass
cannon with powerful elemental attacks
and light armor Catherine was taking a
nap at launch and while all her friends
level 30
she's only level 1 but that's okay
because in anthem friends of any level
can play together to earn experience and
great reward gum leading down follow it
we should find the source
hang on something isn't right
okay so that Titan was way too powerful
for our squad at least for today so it
was wise to avoid him but emergent world
events just like the Titan can happen
throughout the world of anthem and it's
a really important point because what it
means is every time you go out and
explore the world you'll have a totally
different experience that yields
different rewards by now you've probably
noticed that reversal plays a really
important role in anthem as you run fly
and swim through above and below the
world you can discover some pretty
amazing things like right now our squad
just discovered the secret underwater
entrance to the scar stronghold
strongholds are a four-player mode that
give greater rewards by taking on
greater challenges once you discover a
stronghold you'll have access to it from
your map at the start of any expedition
looks like the scars of laid mines in
this tunnel Jen show us how a colossus
deals with mines
[Music]
combos are a really important part of
group play using certain abilities
together allows you to combo for extra
effects like bonus damage I feel a
little bad for making fun of Kathryn
earlier so let's see if we can have her
set up a combo up ahead
[Music]
nice combo
so right there Catherine called down a
lightning storm and Jen used her railgun
to combo for massive bonus damage
there's a shader edit wait something's
off get a closer look with you night has
fallen in the world of anthem and the
creatures that inhabit the darkness are
out on the prowl but honestly that's the
story for another day because right now
we have that giant thing to deal with
I don't know what they've done to that
relic but it's getting worse by the
minute see those radiant pieces of
energy there echoes from the anthem of
creation return them to the relic you've
got to silence it fast this will be the
first real challenge for our squad
we have snipers to the right the shape
interface below US troops in the middle
and then all the way to the left we have
those turrets our squad can approach
this in a lot of different ways but Jen
you're the expert so over to you
looks like jen is sending our squad to
hit the snipers first
in the top right hand corner of the
screen you can see our objective is to
find all six echoes and take them to the
shape interface so up ahead Silla has
one on his back in the colossus and here
you can see Jen has two so Silla just
put one in when we get these and that'll
be three out of six and we're halfway
done there a problem now is we have to
go through those troops in the middle to
find the rest
a gin used her railgun to knock that
elite out of the sky
lots of scars headed your way watch out
we can see the range is hovering the top
left getting ready to do something looks
like it might be yep first grenade al
Jim's gonna use her multi motor for a
big shadow combo our eye good job Jan
okay we cleared out the middle the last
thing left of these two tarts we could
take them head-on a flank
looks like Jenn's gonna try to brute
force this first one
okay didn't quite get they're gonna have
to flank behind and hit those weak
points
okay our squads now cleared out all the
enemies in this area the last thing left
to do is get those three echoes and drop
them off to silence the relic
it's got silence disaster averted
do you think we get a bonus for wait
something's happening what the hell was
that I think that was whatever laid all
the eggs around here the sound came from
below your position with some pretty
awesome teamwork our squad was able to
silence this relic relics are littered
throughout the world left there by the
shapers abandoned and volatile but for
right now the mystery of the sky weapon
is taking us deeper and deeper into this
stronghold
the scouts were using those XS something
making acid properly so the job's not
done until we get rid of all the eggs on
the plus side this definitely cancel
what hazard pay
the environment seems to be changing I
have a bad feeling there are more than
just scars in this stronghold
[Music]
strongholds are a long-form adventure so
in the interest of time we're going to
skip ahead in the action
all right Jen let's show off some
different weapons up ahead let's have
Scylla in front with his flamethrower
and have you support him with your
grenade launcher
[Music]
as you play anthem you'll collect a
whole lotta loot and Luke plays a really
important role in anthem not just
because it makes you more powerful but
also because it allows you to create
different loadouts to tackle a wide
variety of different situations is that
you're supposed to tell me right just be
careful
our freelancers just discovered an
ancient arcanist resonance interesting
wall items and materials are scattered
throughout the world of anthem for you
to discover and collect by now you've
probably noticed that our squad has some
pretty awesome abilities in particular
the Colossus has a legendary multi motor
and the Ranger has a legendary frost
grenade Luke comes in many different
rarities and legendary items are very
hard to come by if you get your hands on
one they have special bonuses that make
you more powerful and I have a feeling
our squads gonna need all the power they
can get for what lies ahead
that's big very good luck
all right so our squad has a lot of
different things to deal with here we
have the smaller soldiers that if left
unchecked will totally overrun our squad
and then we have the swamp tyrant
herself now the swamp tyrant has three
big sacks on her back and they're her
weak points
our squad has to focus on the weak
points to cause massive bonus damage
now Jen gets too close to you she'll
take a lot of damage from the swamp
tyrants frontal attack but if she tries
to stay too far Baxter get caught in her
web
legendary multi-modal right on that weak
point is perfect
it looks like still managed to light her
on fire this flamethrower and now she's
taking a lot of extra damage
so I've managed to destroy one of the
sacks leaving the slum tyrant vulnerable
by using teamwork and focusing on her
weak points
our squad has caused the swamp tyrant to
tree
it looks like she's called for help now
Scott has to take control of this choke
point to make sure they're not overrun
what we really need is Scylla to get his
flame wall out there we go nice job
Scylla maybe a lightning strike here
from the storm would be helpful awesome
and Jenna dukundra combo here would be
great maybe that multi mortar
alright looks like our squad now has
everything well in hand but the form
tyrant is back
Jen's gonna get out of here she's gonna
take a lot of damage
I still asset the swamp tyrant on fire
again every javelin has a powerful
ultimate abilities that can turn the
tide of battle in your favor
but this battle isn't over yet
thank you all for watching our live
gameplay experience today anthem will be
available in February 22nd for PC Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 for more
information go to anthem game calm
you